[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to the table my
name is Karen and we are live this
Sunday evening and we're so glad you're
here make sure as you tune in you
comment below so that we can welcome you
personally I want to wish all the dads
out there a very Happy Father's Day your
day is going well and I also realize
that today can be difficult for some
people as well so if you're experiencing
grief or sadness or mixed emotions I
just want to say that we see you we
acknowledge your pain we love you and we
pray comfort over you I have one
announcement tonight and really really
excited to announce this our friends at
centerpiece a nonprofit organization
here in the DFW area is going to be
holding a conference called the e3
conference this October so I want you to
save the date for October 22nd through
the 24th and if you are part of the
LGBTQ community if you are a parent or
family member of someone who identifies
as LGBTQ if you're a friend or an ally a
pastor a church leader there's going to
be something for you at this conference
and the theme of this year's conference
is how do we stay together when we don't
agree and rumor has it that our very own
brits hillford will be participating on
one of the panels we are waiting to see
obviously with all of the coated stuff
whether this will be an online or an
in-person conference or some combination
of the two but it will definitely be
happening so I just want you to save the
date for October and we'll be sure to
keep you posted with more details as
they come let's pray and then we'll dive
into worship God we Center on you
tonight you are a firm foundation
the midst of chaos and uncertainty you
are our refuge and Our Strength our hope
and our anchor may our eyes ears and
hearts open in new ways to you in Jesus
name Amen
come and tear down the walls of build up
every wall every wall it's you deserve
every piece
[Music]
I am bringing my to you in the open
hands closer and closer you're drawing
me in
as the depths of my heart lay before you
again
[Music]
[Applause]
close down the walls of
[Music]
I am
[Applause]
[Music]
I love that song everyone needs to go
check out common hymnal if you have not
done that before they are a great group
of people writing music that represents
the general population of the kingdom of
God and not just the I mean their heart
is to communicate something more than
just the middle to upper-class white
straight male version of Christianity
and it has been a great resource and a
great community for me to watch and to
glean from and I've loved their music
and been challenged by them and so
anyways that was a song that Josh and
Joe just did by them and yeah I
encourage you guys to check it out thank
you guys for being with us I wanted to
read this poem um called for one who is
exhausted a blessing it's by John
O'Donoghue and when we first were coming
into the pandemic season I may have
shared with some of you how like it was
almost a gift to me in some ways not to
diminish the pain and hardship that so
many people have experienced from covin
19 and are still experiencing but just
the forced time at home the forced
slowdown that it brought for me was much
needed I had just been spinning my
wheels and kind of using busyness as an
excuse to not take time to be quiet to
be silent or even just to get some space
for myself and the hamster wheel was
just a little bit out of control and I
started to find that I was just so
thankful and almost afraid to go back to
life pre Kovas because I just felt like
I was burnt
I was just maxed out my capacity and
when I came across this poem I just was
suddenly
like this has given words to my
experience and so I wanted to share it
with you guys and play a song called
House upon a hill that just kind of both
of them are just kind of emphasizing
that need that we have as humans to slow
down and to not swallow ourselves in the
busy hectic schedules that can fill our
life so I hope for you guys it it also
names some things and after we read it I
just wanted to also go back and
highlight a couple phrases that for me
we're very eye-opening that just felt
like they named something specific that
I needed to hear so yeah when the rhythm
of the heart becomes hectic take time
takes on the strain until it breaks then
all the unattended stress falls in on
the mind like an endless increasing wait
the light in the mind becomes dim things
you could take in your stride before now
become labor some events of will
weariness invades your spirit gravity
begins falling inside of you dragging
down every bone the tide you never
valued has gone out and you are marooned
on unsure ground something within you
has closed down and you cannot push
yourself back to life you have been
forced to enter empty time the desire
that drove you has relinquished there is
nothing else to do now but rest and
patiently learn to receive the self you
have forsaken in the race of days at
first your thinking your thinking will
darken and sadness take over like
listless weather the flow of unwept
tears will frighten you you have
traveled too fast over false ground now
your soul has come to take you back take
refuge in your senses open up to the
small miracles you rushed through be
come inclined to watch the way of rain
when it falls slow and free imitate the
habit of Twilight taking time to open
the well of color that fostered the
brightness of day draw alongside the
silence of stone until its calmness can
claim you be excessively gentle with
yourself stay clear of those vexed in
spirit learn to linger around someone of
ease who feels they have all the time in
the world gradually you will return to
yourself having learned a new respect
for your heart and the joy that dwells
far within slow time these are some of
the phrases that I loved in there
the tides you never valued has gone out
the self you have forsaken in the race
of days you traveled too fast over false
ground its calmness can claim you linger
around someone of ease you will return
to yourself
[Music]
you
Jesus thank you for times to be quiet
times were forced to slow down and face
ourselves listen to our hearts listen to
your police
[Music]
help us to keep listening
it's quiet in this house up on the hill
you won't mind it
some things you can't know till your
cell in the silence let your spinning
thought slow down in the stillness
things have a way of working out me to
introduce myself
[Music]
nothing
I'll meet you in the house up on the
hill how I want to show you I am me to
introduce myself
[Music]
you must think goodnight eggs i standing
on this free don't have to reach for me
class this is where I am
[Music]
Jesus we love you we're so grateful for
who you are
pray God that you'll continue to speak
to us in the quiet moments and in the
busyness god help us to find you in both
thank you for being a good God and a
good father to us we love you amen
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening my friends grace and peace
huge thank you to Mindy and Josh and Joe
music and Karen for the welcome it's
just yeah it's really good to be with
you all and especially those of you who
are new here welcome welcome to the
table and I see we've got a number of
things so happy Father's Day and I also
wanted to to say thank you to our
panelists from last week Chris in India
Juanita as well as Karen who was kind of
the the moderator for that time it was
just such a it was a powerful
conversation and I'm just I'm really
grateful for your just that that sense
of like bravery and I know it was a
sacrifice and emotional takes an
emotional toll to do that so I'm
grateful and thank you for taking the
time so we are kicking off a new series
this will be kind of our summer series
titled simply Luke and we're of course
kind of going through the the Gospel of
Luke so this is the the third book in
the New Testament so you have Matthew
Mark Luke and it's one of the four
Gospels that that really tells the story
of Jesus so the book was written
somewhere between like ad 60 to 280 so
about thirty to fifty years after
Christ's resurrection and ascension and
the gospel it opens with this this
introduction so the whole gospel is kind
of framed in this this way
it says Luke Luke chapter 1 starting in
verse 1 many have undertaken to draw up
an account of the things that have been
fulfilled among us just as they were
handed down to us by those who were from
the first or those who from the first
were I would
is in servants of the word with this in
mind since I myself have carefully
investigated everything from the
beginning Luke says I too decided to
write an orderly account for you most
excellent Theophilus so that you may
know the certainty of the things you
have been taught so let's begin with a
little bit of just background on this
book now I'm gonna be really nerdy for
about five minutes don't worry the whole
message will not be this academic but I
do I do think some just background
information on the book is important
even for those who've maybe you've read
it for years and yet you might not
really kind of understand some of the
background to it um so we don't know who
exactly Theophilus was apparently he was
someone interested in the Christian
faith perhaps a person who was like
helping to fund Luke's research and
writing project so that's when it says
there I think it's around verse three or
so that you know most excellent
Theophilus like he's addressing this
book to this person but we don't exactly
know much about Theophilus now reading
passages like the one I just did I think
we kind of a tendency to misunderstand
what really the four Gospels as a whole
are all about so you have Matthew Mark
Luke John and we tend to think that
they're all doing the same thing so you
know Matthew he's just like Luke and it
looks just like John and in the thing we
think they are doing is probably one of
two things um either we think they're
doing a biography of Jesus or a history
of Jesus so a biography this would be
someone who's who's trying to tell the
story of a person's life with a certain
um emphasis on their personal problems
in their internal struggles and yet if
you read Luke that's not so much what's
happening here you know you're not
really in the mind of Jesus at all it's
yeah this is not like a first-person
like interview with Jesus or something
um so with that mind then people can a
shift to option B and they say okay so
it's not so much biography it's it's
like
history and what they tend though they
have in mind is like a modern you know
Luke as the modern historian who's kind
of trying to remain objective and
removed from from his or her object of
study you know this would be a person
like historian who's just interested in
the facts and arranging them as they
come to her so the problem with this
option is is a few thing so a that
post-modernism has certainly shown um
that this just isn't really how
historians actually operate in the
modern period that's kind of how they
said they operated but you know it just
isn't really so like of course striving
for objectivity is fine since that's
good you know you don't want to
intentionally mislead people and yet as
a historian what are you doing you're
telling a story all right I mean any
good history book isn't just like a
bunch of random facts like bullet points
but it's it's interpreted right and so
in the story you're telling is guided by
what you as the historian have decided
ahead of time are the key moments the
key insights the key like turning points
or the main things right so good
historians are good storytellers and
that's different than a biologist doing
a science experiment now which is why
this gospel it's not so much some quasi
scientific attempt by Luke to
dispassionately relate to you a history
of Jesus like yes it involves history of
course and in facts but but a simple
history is just not quite what Luke is
doing either okay so if Luke is neither
a pure biographer nor a pure historian
what on earth is he doing well scholar
David Jeffrey the way he put it I
thought was really sharp he said Luke's
account he's really more like a literary
version of a documentary film so now
Luke of course he didn't have access to
you know video cameras so instead what
do you do he used writing but what a
documentary does is
it brings together the views of others
on a particular topic or event and then
it leaves those into something that is a
clear and compelling narrative so you
see Luke him himself he was not a direct
disciple of Jesus instead he was an
educated person who took it upon himself
to basically take the time and energy to
interview people who were themselves
eyewitnesses of Christ and then Luke our
documentarian compiles those accounts
into a story of the life of Christ all
right so I hope that's enough background
hope I hope our viewers didn't just drop
to 0
um I can't see Facebook right now like
in the details so but that's your
history okay so let's get into our
message tonight so the title is the
silence and I want to begin Luke chapter
1 verse 5 it says in the time of Herod
king of Judea there was a priest named
Zechariah who belonged to the priestly
division of Abijah his wife Elizabeth
was also a descendant of Aaron both of
them were righteous in the sight of God
observing all the Lord's commands and
decrees blamelessly but they were
childless because Elizabeth was not able
to conceive and they were both very old
once when Zacharias division was on duty
and he was serving as priest before God
he was chosen by lot according to the
custom of the priesthood to go into the
temple of the Lord and burn incense when
the time for the burning of incense came
all the assembled worshippers were
praying outside so you can see this is
like a very kind of holy moment all that
the church all the people gathered there
the temple one priest goes in to this
kind the inner chamber to light this
incense and it's Zachariah then an angel
of the Lord appeared him standing at the
right side of the altar of incense and
when Zechariah saw him he was startled
and was gripped with fear but the angel
said to him do
be afraid Zechariah your prayer has been
heard your wife Elizabeth will bear you
a son and you are to call him John he
would be a joy and a delight to you many
will rejoice because of his birth for he
will be great in the sight of the Lord
he is never to take wine or other
fermented drink he will be filled with
the Holy Spirit
even before he is born he will bring
back many of the people of Israel to the
Lord their God he will go on before the
Lord in the spirit and power of Elijah
the the famous prophet Elijah to turn
the hearts of the parents to their
children in the disobedient to the
wisdom of the righteous to make ready a
people prepared for the Lord it's quite
a speech and then Zechariah asked the
angel how can I be sure of this I'm an
old man and my wife is well along in
years the angel said to him I am Gabriel
I stand in the presence of God and I
have been sent to speak to you and to
tell you this good news and now you will
be silent and not able to speak until
the day this happens because you did not
believe my words which will come true at
their appointed time now the truth is
that Zechariah and this by the way you
can tell this is not the story of the
birth of Jesus wrong names right this is
about John who would be kind of the
forerunner the the one who would go
before Jesus to prepare the people's
hearts for Jesus so that's this is the
birth of John the Baptist so you can
tell though that the truth is that
Zechariah John's father he was not like
this is not a bad person
verse 6 in fact is very clear that he
was righteous in the sight of God
observing all the Lord's commands
Zechariah is not a bad person Zechariah
you know a church-going person he was a
spiritual person during worship I
imagine that he raised his hands in the
air
when his alarm went off in the morning
he said his prayers he was revered in
the community I mean he was a priest and
an upstanding citizen he did what he was
supposed to do he followed the rules he
kept the commandments but life had
beaten
Zecharia down and it didn't happen all
at once I imagine like he didn't just
lose his faith all at once of course not
but months turned into years as he and
Elizabeth they longed to be pregnant
they longed for a child and they prayed
and they begged God but nothing happened
brothers and sisters life will get us
all it will eat us alive just think back
to your youth you know that that
youthful idealism think back to high
school or if you're in high school think
back to junior high the good old days
remember that person the world was just
just waiting for you to show up with
your talents and awesomeness and men
when we're looking the first blue that
youthful idealism isn't it so easy to
play the critic I mean you know how to
fix the world you know what your parents
should have done differently you know
how to raise kids you know how to make a
million bucks by the time you're 25 or
how to land your dream job or keep the
perfect home and if you're not there yet
well just wait you know I'll figure it
out no time oh my friend's life has a
way of beating us down when the layoffs
happen when the marriage falls apart
when the child makes the stupidest
decision of their life or perhaps like
Zechariah and Elizabeth there is no
child
at all when your best friend gets cancer
when the church rejects you when chronic
pain and illness haunt you when racism
discourages and fills you with fear when
a virus and a quarantine just keep
dragging out forever
slowly wearing down your faith and when
finances with they're like a plant
exposed to a Texas summer and slowly
what happens that youthful idealism
cracks under the pressure of life and it
gives way to eight a creeping cynicism
and of course you still go through the
motions don't get me wrong I mean you're
not going off the deep end
at least not too much maybe a little but
you keep up appearances and like
Zechariah you go through the routines
and you do your duty are you tracking
with me but but a part of you that that
faith part of you that belief that life
in God are good its withering and not
even the appearance of old Gabriel
himself can change that fact
I love how local pastor T Jakes he puts
it this way he says life has a way of
shutting our mouths you see the angel
Gabriel shut Zacharias mouth but it's
life that shuts our mouth but the story
continues
so Elizabeth Sakurai's wife miracle of
miracles she does indeed become pregnant
and so for nine months she was nurturing
this this little miracle this little
baby and in for nine months
Zachariah was silent but here's the
interesting thing
something was growing in Zechariah - did
you think he had a have some time for
reflection you think I mean think about
it he literally we know this from later
in the story he had to write out
anything he wanted to say what would
that do to your communication levels you
do you think Zechariah had had a little
time to himself I see I think as our
youthful idealism gives way as it breaks
up as it flounders as life shuts our
mouths I believe that that silence that
season where you just don't have any
answers for people that silence God
calls you into is is gonna do one of two
things it is either going to become a
tune or a womb it's either going to be a
place where faith hope and love go to
die or it's going to be the site of the
birth of something deeper and truer more
rooted like your true self and you know
what it's like in life in the life of
someone who has allowed that silence to
become a tomb when they finally speak
again when they find their voice again
you've been around them what's their
speech like it is bitter and ugly they
cannot speak a positive word they cannot
utter a word of hope and act we even
have a term for them we say they are
cold what do we mean we're talking about
their emotional life right there their
soul like you see cold is shut down cold
is detached cold is unfeeling cold is
emotionally distant it's cold this is
someone who has given up on life but
what is faith people often talk about
faith as though it's against science
like you're someone a faith and I'm
someone of science faith is not about
believing a bunch of non-scientific e
things let me just make that clear it's
in fact it's not even trying to convince
yourself God is real
that is real let faith arise this no
it's not what it's about
instead of faith is how you respond when
life shuts your mouth it's saying look I
may not be able to prove it
but I will live as though God in life
are good I will live and so God in life
are good I will live with courage I
actually think that belief follows faith
it's it's when someone says I will live
as though God in life for good I will
live as though Christ is the way the
truth in the life and then one day they
noticed what huh I believe and and when
we do that what's happened the silence
has become a womb and end it it launches
it propels us into what father Richard
Rohr calls the second half of life you
see the first half of life is about
becoming a some body it's it's when you
care mightily about how many Facebook
Likes and LinkedIn endorsements and
compliments that's on the head that you
receive and it's also the season when
you take every failure and struggle like
very personally oh and and then um but
then that second half of life this is
different this is what happens when life
shuts your mouth in that silence becomes
a womb and we emerge from it and realize
that it was never really about us in the
first place
let me said again we realize it was
never really about us in the first place
it just it just wasn't all about us and
suddenly we're free we're free to serve
God without being so obsessed as to our
effectiveness and our awesome
suddenly we're free to not concern
ourselves so much with what others think
of us we're free to orient our lives to
bring as much good to as many people as
is humanly possible even to our enemies
were free to speak words of life and
hope and healing to be of service to
others in fact in that time in that
season make that transition I'm even
free to realize that there was more than
a touch of ego in both that youthful
idealism I'm going to change the world
emphasis on I'm as well as that kind of
elderly cynicism I stand in judgment
over this crappy world emphasis on eye
and suddenly I'm free even from that
it's what Jesus was naming when he said
that anyone who wants to find their life
must do what must lay it down must allow
the silence to become a wound must
become the servant of all which brings
us back to our story so the nine months
of Elizabeth's pregnancy passes and she
has her little baby boy it's a huge I
mean you can imagine this like complete
miracle she's an elderly woman having
this baby and so all of her neighbors
and relatives are there rejoicing with
her uh and you think I was a cur I oh
good for him now he can speak nope nope
he's still completely silent we pick up
the story in verse 59 on the eighth day
they came to circumcise the child they
were going to name him after his father
Zechariah but his mother spoke up and
said no no he is to be called John and
they said to her there's
no one among your relatives who has that
name so then they made signs to his
father that's how they had to
communicate I guess it's sort of fun
they said that made signs to him when he
could hear and maybe it's that weird
thing where we start to treat people
different anyway so they made signs
awkwardly to his father who can still
hear to find out what he would like to
name the child and so verse 63 he asked
for a writing tablet I imagine him kind
of holding it in a way I can't see what
he's writing but the text says to
everyone's astonishment he wrote his
name is John and in that moment
immediately his mouth was opened and his
tongue set free and what did he do he
began to speak praising God and all the
neighbors were filled with awe and
throughout the hill country of Judea
people were talking about all of these
things you see that's what happens when
your silence when your trial when your
season of suffering becomes a womb
rather than a tomb when you speak now
it's with authority when you speak it's
the truth and people know it's the truth
when you speak your mouth is filled with
praise for God and the people around you
say what happened to him what happened
to her he's different she's different
maybe even a little weird but in really
good way you pray with me
or Jesus we ask for the grace that would
transform our seasons of silence into
wombs of transformation in
new life God that you would take our
suffering and our pain and transform us
into something beautiful in and through
it and so I pray over every person
listening to these words now and in the
days to come that they would not become
bitter that they would not become cold
shut down but they would trust again
love again that you would set their
tongues free they would it would be able
to speak the true word the beautiful
word the good word to themselves to
their families friends and others God
make us a community of people who can do
that it's in the powerful and
life-changing name of Jesus that I pray
amen
[Music]
in the presence of my enemies I raise
the hallelujah louder than me unbelief
I raise the hallelujah weapon is a
melody I raise the hallelujah heaven
comes to fight for me
[Music]
the king
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks so much for joining us tonight I
hope that the service was a blessing to
you and a reminder that you are not
alone I want to give a heartfelt thanks
to those of you who continue to give to
the table during this time and the the
financial gifts that you give to the
table
help us to in turn help our community
and one of the organizations in the sexy
area that we partner with is five loaves
food pantry and as you can imagine with
kovat they are getting slammed right now
with requests and they do such good work
and so I wanted to just highlight them
and for those of you that do want to
give in a tangible way to the sexy
community to be able to provide food for
families and individuals in need right
now you can go to their website and give
they're doing really really good work
in our area as we close out I'll leave
you with this benediction may the Lord
bless you and protect you may the Lord
make his face shine upon you may the
Lord look with favor on you and give you
peace be blessed you are loved and we
hope to see you next week bye-bye